at this point you may wonder why you
need a strong password in the first
place
even if most websites are safe there is
still a danger that someone will try to
access or exploit your information
a strong password is among the most
effective ways to protect your accounts
and personal information from hackers
you should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password
password managers are also recommended
to help remember the created passwords
for convenience of usage
with that being said let's take a look
at the topics we are covering today
we start by learning about the state of
password cracking in today's world and
why creating strong passwords is an
absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faces have gone in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords
along with other critical personal
information
let's start by learning about why strong
passwords have become an absolute
necessity
one of the most common ways that hackers
break into computers is by guessing
passwords
simple and commonly used passwords
enable intruders to easily gain access
and control a computing device
conversely a password that is difficult
to guess makes it prohibitively
difficult for common hackers to break
into a machine and will force them to
look for another target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that one's computer
will fall victim to an unwanted
intrusion
many individuals opt to tie their
websites to something they can readily
recall to generally easy memorable
combos however this does not make the
password unique in fact it's the reverse
passwords are handled by 53 percent of
individuals using their recollections
and memory
with modern computational standards
simple passwords take seconds and a
couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forced
according to global surveys more than 60
of people use the same passwords for
their personal and job applications
while this may allow the user never to
forget the password it makes a single
point of failure the only pin to drop
if one of the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked
to further elaborate on how you can
create strong passwords let's go through
some of the guidelines
let's go through some do's and don'ts to
understand how to create new passwords
for accounts
it is recommended to keep the password
length at least 12 characters to ensure
brute forcing to be difficult
a combination of upper and lower case
alphabets is an absolute necessity when
creating strong passwords
it is also recommended to use numerics
along with those alphabets to create a
complicated password
finally special characters help in
making a password much more brute force
resistant than any number of alphabets
or letters can make moving over to the
don't section
it's absolutely not recommended to keep
simple dictionary terms such as computer
or even the word password as your
credential because those are very easy
to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list
similarly changing a single alphabet or
a single character in a dictionary word
does not make it brute force's instant
considering there are already algorithms
present that can counter the stack deck
using the same character multiple times
in a password also reduces the strength
and makes it easier to crack for hackers
apart from using single characters
multiple times following patterns that
are present on this traditional english
keyboard such as key w erty
or the line below the main alphabet such
as the zxcv bnm etc make it easier to
guess since these are once again common
combinations that are present in word
list already
finally the most important part being
not using personal information such as
birthdays addresses and other important
information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done
made by social media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more easier
now that you understand how to create
strong password
look at how pass phrases have become
prevalent as a replacement for plain
text passwords
a passphrase is a sentence like string
of words used for authentication that is
longer than a traditional password easy
to remember and difficult to crack
typical passwords range on an average
from 8 to 16 characters while
passphrases can reach up to 100
characters or more
using a long fast phrase instead of a
short password to create a digital
signature is one of the many ways that
users can strengthen the security of
their data devices and accounts the
longer a passphrase is the more likely a
user is to incorporate bits of entropy
or factors that make it less predictable
to potential attackers
as more websites applications and
services increase the user security
requirements a passphrase is a fast and
easy way to meet these criterias
let's take a look at some of the
advantages that pass faces have over
common passwords
passphrases are simpler to remember than
just a random assortment of symbols and
characters
it's easier to comprehend a line from
your favorite song or a quotation than a
short but difficult password
passwords are reasonably easy for humans
and robots to guess or crack
online thieves have also advanced and
created cutting-edge hacking tools to
crack even the most complex passwords
passphrases are nearly hard to crack
since most efficient password tracking
programs fail at approximately 10
characters
as a result even the most sophisticated
cracking tool will be unable to guess
brute force or precompute these
passwords
complies with password setting rules
with ease passphrases
the usage of punctuation and upper and
lowercase passwords satisfy the password
complexity criteria
most operating systems and apps support
passphrases
phrases of up to 1.7 characters are
permitted on all major operating systems
including windows linux and mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier passphrases
but when creating a strong password the
major problem people come across is
remembering these passwords or the
passphrases
this is where you can find a use for a
password manager
when you establish accounts or change
passwords password managers generate new
strong passwords and they keep all of
them in one place protected by a single
strong master password
if you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and passphrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this
this implies that everyone may use the
most recent suggestions for strong
passwords such as extended phrases
symbols grammar and capitalization
password managers enable consumers to
write a single master password and
automatically fill each website with
their own unique set of credentials
and not just passwords credit card
information may be stored securely with
several password managers
some others make multi-factor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login inputs
among the global players and password
managers services like bitwarden keepass
and dashlane have been running for years
now and are very worthy recommendations
if you want to get started with password
management
hope you learned something new today if
you have any questions please feel free
to ask us in the comment section below
and we will get back to you as soon as
possible
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this and thank you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here